here's a dramatization about how the
pitch for sex tape went hey you know
that really interesting and original
script we got in today yeah yeah throw
that out we're gonna make sex tape sex
tape is directed by Jake Kasdan and
stars Jason Segel and Cameron Diaz the
team that brought you bad teacher this
movies about a couple that decides their
sex life is just going so they decide to
make a sex tape to try to liven things
up and accidentally send it to all of
their friends so they have to spend the
rest of the movie trying to get that
file back so that their lives aren't
ruined movies should really be called
sex file I like Jason Segel I think he's
a really funny guy and in the past he's
proven himself to be a pretty capable
comedy writer Cameron Diaz used to get
really good performances but now she
really just stars in a string of
terrible comedies sex tape is no
different in fact this is one of the
worst movies I've seen all year know
what you're thinking Chris why is this
movie so bad why are you hating on this
movie they're not trying to be Oscar
worthy they're not trying to be great
why wouldn't a movie try to be great
every movie should try to be great if
you're gonna have an opportunity to make
a good movie make one because they
didn't seem to care at all about that
while they were writing the script for
this movie this movie was so maddeningly
unfunny that I could not believe that so
many funny people got together in a room
and decided to make this thing it really
is a movie with one idea possibly two
the first one being hey let's make a
movie in which we can use the iPad a
whole bunch of times where we can talk
about its features show its features and
get a ton of advertising money from
Apple ID number two is hey let's make a
funny movie about sex and we'll have sex
in the title and it'll make money
because sex the most surprising thing
about this movie is that it's actually a
Sony Pictures movie with so many Apple
products in this film I'm surprised they
actually endorsed this movie if you've
seen the trailer for this movie not only
have you seen every single part that's
even remotely funny in the movie but you
know exactly where it's going if you
watch the trailer for this movie you
know they're going to have sex they're
going to record it and they're going to
spend the rest of the movie in a whole
bunch of embarrassing conversations in
which they try to avoid the fact that
they made a sex tape and a whole bunch
of people are seeing it and it's truly
one of those movies in which every
character in it is completely
unrealistic and fake everyone this movie
is a movie character like every
character in this movie
is insane there at this movie level
where you're a character and you're
reading dialogue that's really really
funny but it's stuff that no one would
ever say so the entire movies plot
doesn't work because no one in the movie
feels like an actual person the movie
tries to set up a realistic relationship
in which a man in a woman's marriage has
gotten to that point where it's just not
really happening for them anymore
and from that semi-realistic set up then
starts this movie in which every
character is a cartoon people say and do
things that are so idiotic ly stupid
they just aren't funny because you can't
stop but realize it's so fake now there
are movies in which that works like Dumb
and Dumber for instance but that's a
movie about two incredibly dumb people
they're supposed to do things like that
in a movie that sets up two characters
that are supposed to be smart and
apparently filthy stinking rich because
they can just give away thousands of
dollars without batting an eye in this
movie these very rich very smart people
who have a nice house a nice family do
the dumbest things ever throughout this
entire movie it's also one of those
movies in which the filmmakers assume
that everyone who watches this movie is
exactly like them because everyone in
this movie is like this perfect American
family with two children a ton of money
and no one knows what these people do
for a living they just have all this
money okay so I said all that but is it
funny no it's not funny at all there
isn't a single joke that hit for me in
this movie it was just whoops a whole
bunch of people saw our sex tape time to
be really embarrassing and chase around
and fall out of windows and get bit by
dogs you're making a comedy you have but
one goal make me laugh
I didn't laugh I love to laugh in movies
I love to watch movies that are funny
this movie just wasn't funny it was a
painful excuse to use sex as a marketing
tool in which an entire movie revolves
around whoops lost my sex tape Wow let's
make a 90-minute movie about that and
maybe we can do some Apple product
placement along the way this is one of
the worst movies I've seen so far this
year Jason Segel is not funny in the
film despite the fact that I like him
Cameron Diaz is Cameron Diaz in the
movie again you look and there's Cameron
Diaz she's not playing a character all
the supporting characters are
also so incredibly fake that there's
just nothing real that can come out of
these situations that are supposed to be
funny sex tape you get an F you are a
terrible terrible excuse for a comedy do
not see this film go watch dawn of the
Planet of the Apes again please because
that movie actually deserves your funds
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes